Die Provinz León im Nordwesten Spaniens.
Sie sind schon seit
sieben Uhr auf den Beinen:
Martin, seine Lebensgefährtin
Maja und die beiden Kinder.
26 Kilometer wollen
sie heute zurücklegen,
auf dem Camino,
wie die Pilger ihn hier nennen,
den berühmten Jakobsweg
im Norden Spaniens.
Es ist am Anfang ’n bisschen ungewohnt,
bis man so in den Trott reinkommt,
und dann ist es …
dann entschleunigt das Ganze.
Viele haben Stress auf der Arbeit,
Familie – das erschlägt einen.
Und hier hat man einfach die Ruhe,
man kann total abschalten.
Der Weg, der verzaubert
einen so ’n bisschen.
Alle gehen in die gleiche Richtung,
und das hat man im Leben nie.
Der Camino ist die finale Etappe
des Jakobsweges,
eines europäischen Netzes
aus Pilgerwegen.
Durch viele Länder weisen
die Jakobsmuscheln
nach Santiago de Compostela,
dem Zielort des Jakobsweges
im Westen der Region Galicien.
Dorthin wollen auch Martin,
Maja und die beiden Töchter:
dreihundert Kilometer in drei Wochen –
bei 35 Grad im Schatten
eine körperliche Grenzerfahrung.
Gerade deswegen hat das Pilgern
für sie etwas Befreiendes.
Man hat auf jeden Fall sehr viel Zeit,
über sich selbst
und den Alltag nachzudenken,
weil man ja vor allem eine Pause hat.
Und hier hat man nur
den Rucksack zu schleppen,
und das ist die einzige Last,
die man hat.
Pilgern scheint vielen etwas zu geben,
das sie im Alltag nicht finden.
Mehr als 250.000 Menschen
pilgerten 2015 auf dem Jakobsweg –
fast dreimal so viele
wie vor gut zehn Jahren.
Der alte Pilgerpfad ist zu einem Eldorado
für moderne Sinnsucher geworden.
Auch Stefan Albus war
auf dem Jakobsweg unterwegs.
Der Journalist hat
ein Buch darüber geschrieben.
Was das Pilgern mit einem macht
und vor allem warum mittlerweile
so viele Menschen pilgern,
darauf gibt das Buch Antworten.
Ich glaube, dass wir in einer Zeit leben,
in der der Mensch,
die Persönlichkeit,
immer unwichtiger wird.
Die Arbeit wird immer dichter,
man muss immer mehr arbeiten
fürs selbe Geld.
Der Stress steigt.
Und immer mehr Menschen
haben das Gefühl:
Moment mal, in meinem Leben geht’s
gar nicht mehr um mich.
Was kann ich da machen,
wie komme ich da raus,
wie kann ich wieder Fuß fassen,
wie kann ich mich wieder spüren?
Der Grundstein des Jakobsweges
wurde vor genau 1200 Jahren gelegt,
mit der Bestattung der Reliquien
des Apostels Jakobus des Älteren.
Christen pilgerten fortan nach Santiago,
um sich ihrer Sünden zu entledigen.
Religiosität ist heute weniger wichtig,
es zählt anderes.
Auf dem Pilgerweg finden
viele Leute zu sich selbst,
und Selbsterkenntnis ist durchaus ein
erster wichtiger Schritt zur Spiritualität.
Wenn man sich auf den Weg macht,
auf einen Weg macht,
von dem man weiß,
seit 1000 Jahren gehen da Leute lang,
um spirituelle Erfahrungen zu machen,
ich glaube, dann fühlt man sich mit diesen
Menschen irgendwie innerlich verbunden.
Dieses Gefühl, sich einzureihen
in eine tausendjährige Geschichte,
das ist einfach großartig.
In Deutschland löste der Bestseller
„Ich bin dann mal weg“
im Jahr 2006 einen Pilgerboom aus.
Darin beschreibt der deutsche
Entertainer Hape Kerkeling
seine Reise auf dem Jakobsweg,
die später auch fürs Kino verfilmt wurde.
Ich komme alleine klar.
Ich hab's kapiert.
Eigentlich könnte ich jetzt
nach Hause fahren.
Aber warum sollte ich?
Ein unentbehrliches Accessoire
auf dem Jakobsweg ist der Pilgerpass.
Die Stempel bekommt man in Herbergen
und Kirchen am Wegesrand.
Wer nachweisen kann, mindestens
100 Kilometer gelaufen zu sein,
bekommt in Santiago de Compostela
eine Pilgerurkunde.
Die abgelegenen Dörfer am Camino
erleben seit dem Anstieg der Pilgerzahlen
einen wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung.
Vielerorts sind Pilgerherbergen entstanden.
Auch Maja, Martin und die Kinder
übernachten in einer Herberge.
Die Unterkünfte sind einfach,
der heimische Überfluss ist weit entfernt.
Für viele ein lehrreiches Erlebnis.
Wenn man nach Hause kommt,
ist man kein anderer Mensch,
aber man …
man weiß, dass man mit
wenig Sachen am Tag leben kann.
Man braucht das alles gar nicht.
Alles nur, was man
auf dem Rücken trägt,
ist das Wichtige für den Tag.
Am nächsten Tag geht es weiter,
Richtung Westen nach
Santiago de Compostela.
Schritt für Schritt
auf der Suche nach Sinn.